Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
This will be my full Ahsoka
Episode 8 Finale Video.
There were a whole bunch of cliffhangers,
but a whole bunch of Easter eggs,
so we'll break it all down.
They paid off a bunch of theories
during season 2, especially
what was going on with the Mortis gods.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
I will do videos for Ahsoka Season 2
and explain what's happening next.
I've got a couple of videos planned
after this
to we're also doing the giveaway
for the Mandalorian Blu rays.
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber
and post all your theories
for Ahsoka season 2 in The Mandalorian
Season 4 careful for spoilers from
the episode if you haven't seen it yet.
We'll just start at the beginning, work
our way through shot by shots,
talking about Easter eggs, WTF moments
and how this is all basically leading up
setting up the Thrawn movie
Heir to the Empire,
we actually just had the 15 year
anniversary
of the premiere of the Clone Wars
as they were airing this Ahsoka finale.
So very timely.
it's also the nine year anniversary
of the premiere of Star Wars Rebels.
And the show is kind of like Star Wars
rebels season 5.
the actual episode title was called
The Jedi The Witch in the Warlord,
which is a reference to a morgan Elsbeth,
now a full night's sister in Thrawn.
That Trinity is also a reference
to the end of the episode
with the more or less gods.
The lion is the father, The which is
the daughter in the Warlord is the son.
The title
also kind of reminded me of The Lion,
the Witch in the Wardrobe,
like Ahsoka is Aslan the Witches.
Morgan Elsbeth in the Wardrobe is like
the transport device to the other room.
In this case,
that would be the hyperspace ring.
The actual opening music is interesting
because it started kind of like
an imperial march,
but like a very ominous version
of the Imperial March because it's Thrawn
taking his Nightsister zombie army
back to the main galaxy.
It shows that they haven't raised
all of the Nightsister zombies yet.
There was a shot at the end of the episode
where they pan over the cargo hold
and show you some of what they have,
but it's kind of like a Game of Thrones
situation with the white Walkers.
The whole idea
is that every time they fight a battle
and they kill a bunch of people,
it can increase the size of their army
exponentially across time.
Thrawn starts
fighting battles against the New Republic.
They kill
a bunch of the New Republic soldiers.
They can also raise those back
from the dead,
and they can continue to raise
their Nightsister zombie troopers
to who basically seem unfazed by anything
but getting their heads chopped off.
it's almost exactly the same way the night
King's Army worked on Game of Thrones.
So he's starting out with an army
this big.
Imagine how big it's going to get
by the beginning of the Thrawn movie.
actual opening Scenes of Thrones
Chimera star destroyers.
They finish loading all those dead bodies
they plan to resurrect.
Their troopers are called Night Troopers
two, even the ones that are still alive,
like some of them are still alive,
but some of them have already been dead
and raised back up.
that's also part of what the red bands
tied around all their armor is.
It's not just there for decoration.
Those are nice sister spells that help
raise them from the dead, Thrawn plans
to distract Ahsoka long enough
to prevent them from being a problem
during their final departure procedures
successfully.
As it turns out, as they attach
the Star destroyer to the hyperspace ring.
Basically it works exactly like you saw
during the events of the prequels
like Obi-Wan Kenobi
had a version of this hyperspace ring.
It was just way smaller
because his ship was smaller.
thing about hyperspace too,
is that you can't
just use a normal hyperspace
engine to jump across galaxies
like they're only certain distances that
regular hyperspace engines are good for.
that's why Morgan Elsbeth has special
hyperspace engines that were way, way
larger than you would see
even on a star destroyer by themselves.
And five of them to boot.
It'd be like strapping three car engines
in, like four extra tanks of gas to a car.
The funny thing, too,
during this opening scene,
when Thrawn is preparing to distract Ahsoka
as he tells Morgan Elsbeth
not to get ahead of herself,
other people made assumptions
about the rebellion
being taken care of way too soon,
and he fell victim
to the heroics of a single Jedi.
That's a direct reference to Ezra Bridger
in the finale from Star Wars Rebels
he basically
surprised him with a giant pod of purrgils
when at the time he had 3 star
destroyers, including his chimera star destroyer
and it looked like he would crush them.
That's why he had that very funny line.
Never again.
it was kind of like the rebels were
ten points behind with the final buzzer
about to go off.
And Ezra Bridger came in with the Ghost
crew in a huge upshot to turn the battle
around, stranding Thrawn in the other
galaxy, creating this whole situation.
Reza's kind of implied that if Thrawn
had not been stranded in the other galaxy
during the events of the original trilogy,
the Empire actually would have won.
they start laying the seeds for Theron's
whole relationship with the Nightsister Sisters
kind of falling apart
like this is a very long storyline
that's going to stretch out, but you kind
of see seeds of this in this episode.
He thanked them for their continued help,
but then throughout the episode,
there are couple moments
where they question
the Nightsisters loyalty to Thrawn
and also the Nightsisters
seem that
they start to dislike Thrawn. A lot.
just laying the seeds for them,
eventually betraying him?
Because the whole idea is the Nightsisters
sisters do not care about the Empire
coming back.
They don't really care about Thrawn
either, is sort of like
the enemy of my enemy is my friend kind
of situation, and they're only using him
because they need him to get back to that
main galaxy, to the Darth Amir planet.
the Nightsister's whole goal in
this is just to bring back the witch
kingdom of the death mere.
So they'll just continue to help Thrawn as
long as it serves them until it doesn't.
And then they'll probably betray him.
then they induct Morgan Elspeth
to become a traditional Nightsister,
a full member of their order.
She gets the face, tattoos, the white skin
like people asked when they introduced
the character early on, like,
why does she look like
regular Nightsisters from Clone Wars
This explains that,
like she basically was born in a time
when all the Nightsisters were dead,
so there were no Nightsisters to induct
her into the order and gain this power.
basically, it's them giving her a giant
power upgrade, access to way more power.
They call it a gift of shadows,
so to speak.
Like she has more access to the force now
they also give her the Sword of Talisman,
which is a direct reference
to Mother Talzin from the Clone Wars.
She was the leader of the Nightsisters
in the main galaxy
until she was killed battling Count Dooku.
Here's the thing, though.
The Nightsisters can actually speak
to Nightsisters who have died.
They can also speak across space and time.
basically the Nightsisters
are pulling Mother Talzin's sword
from across galaxies to give it to her.
Like that's how their power works
too bad they can't actually pull each
other across galaxies.
but Morgan Elsbeth,
for instance, in present day,
even though it seems like she's dead,
don't count her out yet.
Like she might not be permitted because so
many people came back from the dead.
In this episode, literally,
because of the Nightsisters
sister's abilities in the force,
she can actually speak across space.
Time to the actual mother Talzin back
during the events of the Clone Wars
before she died or even after death to
practical reason why
Dave Filoni gave her mother
Talzin's sword was obviously, you know,
big Easter egg, big member berries,
but also to match Ahsoka
to make them about on equal footing.
notice that Thrawn
also kind of seems
bemused by this ceremony,
but like I said,
he understands what it means
because during the ceremony
one of the parts of it
involved a morgan Elsbeth swearing
ultimate loyalty to the Nightsisters,
meaning the Thrawn clock
that in understood
it means that she wasn't
loyal to him anymore, then we get another
really cool scene of Ezra constructing
a brand new lightsaber for himself.
I wasn't sure
if he was actually going to do this,
but I'm glad that they did this,
He claims because of his new force
abilities, he doesn't need a lightsaber,
but it's weird to see a Jedi
without a lightsaber.
there's a lot of references
and exposition here
where he learns who Hu Yang really is.
Because remember, he's been gone
this whole time. He never met who Yang
There's a bunch
of jokes about him doing it the wrong way
and how he's taught Patton
since the beginning of the Jedi Order,
almost the beginning of the Jedi Order.
He has schematics for every single light
saber constructed before Order 66.
Obviously, They also use this scene
as a really interesting
way to talk about Kanan Jarrus.
There was a live action Kanan cameo scene
from Freddie Prinze Jr as a picture on
is Ship on the Ghost.
maybe at some point
we'll get a live action.
Freddie Prinze
Jr Kanan Cameo Scene in a bigger way.
But there was so much Anakin Skywalker
throughout the Ahsoka episodes.
I feel like that's the reason
why we didn't see a ton of Kanan stuff.
like,
we're only allowed to have so many force
ghosts and so many dead
Jedi come back on this series.
We're going to focus on Anakin
Skywalker this time.
Next time, we'll hit up
Kanan Jarrus, Force Ghost.
The whole idea with who Yangu, though,
is that he's from the Old Republic.
Like he's
been around for thousands of years.
He tells Ezra that he taught his master,
Kanan Jarrus,
who was Caleb Dume at the time.
That's why he says, Oh, Caleb,
I remember him.
after the events of Order 66, Caleb Dume
changes his name to Kanan Jarrus
when he goes on the run, basically
telling Ezra that he understands.
And now like, Oh, I remember your master.
Now it makes sense why you're this way.
he also gives him a twin hilt
that was the same as Kenan's hilt
on his lightsaber,
saying that when Kanan was a young child,
or when Caleb was a young child
constructing his lightsaber,
he just kept the second one
in case he would ever need in the future.
into Bhoot, Ezra's
new lightsaber is blue, just like Kanan,
so his lightsaber is essentially very,
very similar to Kanan Lightsaber
now with a lot of the same pieces.
doesn't they just make you feel like
we're going
to eventually
get some sort of live action?
Kanan Cameo scene
when they're referencing Kanan,
they also play a little bit of kenan's
theme from Star Wars rebels
it almost seems like he wants to practice
with the new lightsaber with Sabine
because Sabine
is using his old lightsaber.
But because of all this reminiscing
on old times.
Thinking about Kanan
and thinking about their time
during Star Wars
rebels, the crew of the ghost, everything.
This happened in present day, all the
backstory, the drama with the soldier.
She basically runs off to cry He explains
the reason why Ahsoka originally stopped
training Sabine is because she felt like
she was only trained to be a Jedi
because she wanted revenge for the death
of her family in the Mandalorian.
Great Purge,
they explained that Sabine's
family was on the Mandalore planet
They were all killed.
But somehow Sabine learned about it.
Ahsoka prevented her
from going to join the battle,
knowing that she would also be killed to
and Sabine, predictably
just kind of resented her for that.
Like you stop me
from trying to help my family.
So Ahsoka
didn't want her trained to be a Jedi
out of rage, out of a want for revenge,
because she felt like that was the path
to anarchy. Skywalker Darth Vader.
Like she didn't want to have
another Darth Vader on her hands.
you have to remember for a
lot of these characters,
a lot of this backstory,
Ezra was not around,
so he's learning it for the first time.
That's why he's so surprised.
Also, Sabine recapped
the events of the original trilogy to him,
basically like the most epic Star Wars
recap ever.
This is all the stuff you missed. but.
Apparently she left out
some of the important stuff.
Like, Oh, yeah, by the way,
the Empire bombed the entire surface
of the Mandalore planet.
But good news is
we actually got the planet back
when a soldier has be,
start talking about the consequences
of what Sabine has done.
Like yes, Thrawn now has a way back.
I gave the star map to Baylan Skoll.
I shouldn't have done that.
Notice that Ahsoka is way more sanguine
about all of this.
Now she's acting more
like an actual traditional Jedi
master way wiser, way less quick to anger.
as she basically explains,
instead of being that
the same thing happened to her
when she was Sabine's age,
like I made all these choices
that nobody understood at the time.
Nobody believed in me
except for my master.
And again, Skywalker,
he always stood by me no matter what.
So now, in present day, Ahsoka is trying
to pay that same respect to Sabine.
Like, I'll stand with you.
Like, don't worry, you're going to make
a bunch of really dumb choices,
But I'll still be there to support you.
complicated choices that Ahsoka references
is mostly her leaving the Jedi order
in the context of this conversation.
But you can actually fill a couple books
with all the complicated choices
that Ahsoka made,
like choosing to fight Darth Vader
when she knew he was ethnic and Skywalker.
Everything she did during the Clone Wars,
for the most part,
if you have not watched
any like the really big Clone Wars
episodes or Rebels episodes,
I would generally recommend
doing that after this,
especially the Mortis episodes.
We'll get to that in a second too,
because Baylan Skoll is clearly standing
on a statue of the Mortes gods, knowing
all the backstory between the characters,
like watching all those things
that happened to Ahsoka go down,
just make scenes like this hit way harder.
So if you're brand new
to that animated stuff,
I would recommend checking that out
after the Ahsoka finale,
starting with the Mortis episodes.
they have another funny moment
when Ezra tries
to show off his new lightsaber
to Ahsoka like,
Hey, look at my new shiny,
This is awesome.
The tie fighters attack in,
They take them out with the Jedi team up
three way Jedi team up in another
funny scene of Saben making a dumb choice
like accidentally
taking out the tie fighters
by also ramming them kamikaze style
with the okay ship For a minute
I thought this was going to be the way
they explained that
they don't get back to the original galaxy
because the ship is disabled
so they can't write it in the Pujols mouth
the same way,
but they basically fix the ship
by the end of the episode.
the whole idea is
they wanted to have that ground assault
where they actually fight their way up.
The Nightsister Sisters Tower into the Star
destroyer on the other side of things,
Thrawn doesn't look surprised
that they lost the tie fighters.
Like I said,
even though he's sad to have lose men,
he understood that
that was probably going to happen.
The whole point was just distracting
Ahsoka long enough
to allow them to load their dead troopers
so that they could get
to the other galaxy.
Notice that he also gives the dead
tie pilot citations.
This is like commendations
for their services, rewarding them
posthumously because he does treat his men
very well, compared to Darth Vader,
for instance, who killed
almost as many Imperials as the rebels did
Thrawn makes a bunch of Darth Vader
references in the episode
and digs at Ahsoka for Anakin Skywalker,
eventually turning into Darth Vader.
the whole blessing of the Nightsisters
that Morgan Elsbeth says
the Nightsister troopers are going to get.
Are the enchantments through
those red bindings around their armor
that will raise them from the dead,
turning them into nice sister zombies
basically creating an unkillable army
for the most part,
unless you chopped their heads off
This is meant to be the TV shows version
of what book Thrawn used his dark Jedi
for essentially creating a much better,
stronger army
during those books,
Thrawn believed the Emperor secretly used
the force to enhance the Imperial fleet
during battles, making it more powerful,
winning more battles.
So he had his own dark jet.
I did the same thing, basically making
everyone a better fighter, a better pilot
kind of like buffing your entire party
before a giant raid fight
when it seems like he gets kind of sad
when he talks about the volunteer storm
troopers being made aware.
he wants to make sure that they're aware
that they're probably going to die
like the Jedi will probably kill you
and you'll be turned into finger
puppets raised from the dead.
basically, he's
sending a bunch of his own forces
who have survived this whole time
into the galaxy to their death.
Thrawn starts making more and again,
Skywalker references, calling
Ahsoka his apprentice in the whole idea
is that he's doing this evil Sherlock
mind palace thing where he's deducing her
entire strategy from knowing what
anti can Skywalker strategy used to be
the same way that Sherlock can spend
like a second or two with someone
and deduce their entire life story.
when they're breaking
into the temple, evidence
of being used the force
to lift the gate together.
It reminds me exactly of him
doing that with Darth Maul.
There are couple scenes like that
in this episode, like the giant force
jump scenes that they did directly
during Star Wars Rebels.
the only difference with this gate
that they were opening together is
it was way, way bigger than the gates
that Darth
Maul and Ezra
were trying to live together in the force.
you know it's on though
when Ahsoka goes sleeveless like sun's out,
guns out big fight time
they move through the night troopers
pretty easily
like they kind of slice of them
like butter.
But it's all just set up for this
nice sister
zombie twist where they come back to life.
And this is basically what it's going
to look like during the Thrawn movie.
when she asks Ezra if this has happened
before, The reason why he doesn't remember
it happening before is because it was
during the Clone Wars before he was born.
Like, Oh, this happened before.
But it was just a long, long time ago.
the next part of the fight is meant
to give you a good idea
of what their abilities are like.
They aren't quite as good fighters
as when they were alive,
but they're still effective.
And in this state, essentially blaster
proof like shots don't slow them down
and Sabine pretty much cuts one in half
and it almost doesn't even stop it
then Thrawn basically asks Morgan Elsbeth
to sacrifice herself and stay behind.
Notice how sad they seem like
Morgan Elspeth is sad about this.
Thrawn is kind of sad about this,
but as for quote unquote, the empire,
she's also sad that
she won't get to return to the main galaxy
and see the rise of the death mirror.
Notice that Thrawn also has a couple of
shadow troopers stay behind with her too.
They're like a special sect
of stormtroopers
that are more powerful, the normal ones.
But these are also nice sister zombies.
As we find out later that's why
they can eat blast shots to the face
and it doesn't even slow them down.
You also see a little bit
underneath their mask, too.
It looks kind of like
the desiccated corpses
from the nice sister
zombies on the Clone Wars
they finally have an Ahsoka versus Morgan
Elsbeth rematch from all the way back
when she's spanked her on The Mandalorian.
those are a lot of the same
energy of Obi-Wan Kenobi
versus Darth Vader on the Death Star
in a new hope like a soldier tells them,
No, no, no, I'll take care of this.
You go off and do your thing to Obi-Wan
Kenobi,
basically did the same thing
to Luke Skywalker.
Like you have your mission.
I have my mission in their fight scene,
even though it was pretty short,
is way better than their last fight scene.
Like they got away
better with the lightsaber
fight choreography just in general.
You can also tell they spent way more time
doing this scene to Sabine and Ezra
doing the combo force.
Jump is a big callback to him
doing the exact same thing with Darth Maul
Help during rebels inside the Sith Temple.
Darth Maul essentially forced through him
after Ezra had already done
a giant force jump and it was so effective
that he almost overshot the mark
when they're doing this.
They also play some of the classic
John Williams force theme.
most of the music in the episode,
though, is versions of Star Wars
Rebels
theme music mixed into brand new songs.
Sabine chooses
to stay behind and help Ahsoka,
which is meant to pay off who Yang's
whole line from earlier in the season.
Where he says they always did better
when they stayed together
She winds up killing Morgan Elspeth, but
like I said, she might not be perma dead,
even though that giant Nightsister's
sister temple crumbled to the ground.
So we'll see. Like,
I mean, fingers crossed.
But right now it does seem
like she's down for the count.
there are a lot of ways that they can
explain that she survives, that.
then the whole
idea with Ezra is that he impersonates
the Nightsister trooper that he just took out,
disguising himself in his armor
the same way he did during rebels.
They had a bit of a funny moment
here, too,
where he kind of slaps him like, oh,
thanks for the help their buddy
there were a lot of moments like that
during Rebel.
So like a lot of his performance here,
even though it's a brand
new actor playing,
the character is trying to capture
a lot of the energy of Ezra from rebels.
this is also why Sabine
had all those extra stormtrooper helmets
in the background.
Those are helmets
that they wore on Star Wars rebels.
Then Ahsoka calls Hu Yang for an assist
and it's a callback to episode one
when she did the exact same thing.
Running to jump on the ship as that
nice sister temple was also exploding.
Then you notice how the Nine Sisters react
to Thrawn destroying their temple.
Like, Wait, what?
What did you just tell them to do?
You're going to blow up our temple
This will probably grow
to bite him in the ass in the future.
Because remember,
they don't care about Thrawn.
They don't care about the Empire
coming back.
They'll do anything they need to to bring
back the witch kingdom of the Dathomir.
And for now
that just means working with Thrawn
so they'll betray him
the first opportunity they get.
Then he actually reminds us that Ahsoka in
Thrawn had never actually met each other
face to face in person.
They knew each other during Star Wars
rebels, but like,
they never actually had a big face off
that way.
He explains how he was able to deduce her
tactics by learning and again
Skywalker's tactics it also throws
the memory of an IT interface
saying that he knew her master and again
and also knew Darth Vader In a place
she too might fall to the dark side
the same way that Enoch did.
Like, we'll see how similar
you might become to your master.
he also calls her a Ronin.
That's a samurai
whose lord or master has died in.
A lot of the series is inspired
by samurai films
Then Thrawn jumps to hyperspace
and makes it back to the main galaxy,
Ahsoka and the others
return to the Crab Village to regroup
and figure out what to do next.
Essentially with the ship
thinks they can use the space
wheels to get back with a little help
from an Anakin Skywalker.
It looks like Force.
Ghost Sky guy coming in for the assist
helps snips out.
They do explain a little bit about
what happens to the other characters.
Like thankfully
there aren't that big a cliffhangers
like there are cliffhangers,
but they at least tell you a little bit
about what's happening next
with the characters.
Shin Hati returns to the Raiders settlement,
making it seem like she's
going to take over their village
and just use it to survive
until she can figure out how to return,
which might involve something
with Baylan
Skolls playing the world between worlds
and the more less gods.
Or she could also use a soldier ship
to return with them to
Then they finally reveal what Baylan
Skoll has been talking this whole time
and paying off one of my long running
fan theories about the Mortes gods,
the secret power that was calling to him
was the Mortes
gods, Those are the three statues
that he's standing on.
The daughters statues crumbled,
but that also might be symbolic of her
kind of still being alive in the al.
maybe we'll see Mirai
during the Thrawn movie
or during the Mandalorian Season 4
or Ahsoka season 2.
but you can see the statues of the father
like he's
standing on the fist of the father.
And then there's a statue of the son right
next to him.
so the early theory right now
is that Baylan
Skoll wants to become a mortis God
and take their power.
And that's how he's going to end all wars
all over the universe.
that's the level of power
you would need to accomplish that.
I literally just did a video
about how in again,
Skywalker was essentially kind
of doing the same thing
Becoming more like the Mortis gods
replacing their role in the universe,
bringing Baylan to the force
on a more cosmic scale.
even though Baylin is standing
on the face of the father,
he could become
like a new version of the son.
Though
that would be a really easy way for them
to recast the character
and explain why he looks different.
Because this is huge.
Like you would have to pay
this storyline off
and you would have to recast the character
because recently in real life, Rey
Stevenson
passed away. May he rest in peace.
The other thing too, about this
is that he could also be trying to enter
the world between worlds.
that would also give him access
to a lot of power as well.
Generally, though, it seems like
he wants to become more to the more gods
then Thrawn exits hyperspace
in the main galaxy above Dathomir
as they begin preparations
to call the rest of the shadow Council
informed their larger fleet,
showing you the casts of armors.
The Nightsister Troopers
they intend to raise, like I said,
kind of like a Game of Thrones
white walker night King situation
where they can increase
the size of their army
exponentially with the other troops
from the other sides that they kill.
so this army is this big now at the
beginning, think about how big it will be
by the beginning
of the Thrawn movie, basically
like a never ending supply of forces.
then Ezra takes Baylan scholarship,
which he would have stolen
from the Star destroyer at some point
after they return to the main galaxy
to warn Hera in the New Republic
about Thrawn, because now he has the proof
like he is the living proof,
and he's wearing the nicest zombie armor.
So like they can actually see the proof.
notice is actually chopper who recognizes
him first underneath the armor
like oh, hey, bro.
Long time no see what's been going on in
if I didn't mention in my previous videos
the actual voice of chopper is Dave
Filoni.
He was the voice of chopper during rebels.
They just continue to do that
during the live action Ahsoka episodes.
yet to picture Dave Filoni
behind the scenes, recording his dialog,
cursing in Droid.
That's basically what Chopper does.
Like every word
that comes out of his mouth
that isn't like a
yes or no kind of answer is a curse word
Then we get a really cool
Anakin Skywalker Force
Ghost cameo scene,
but they pull it off
in a really interesting way.
they supposed to be looking at a soldier
in through the clouds?
You can actually see the rings
around the planet
and remember that the rings are meant
to be the dead Portugal bones
reminding you
that they can actually find a way
to call the prequels back to them
and use them
to get back to the main galaxy.
but the whole idea here is that Sabine
can't see and can Skywalker.
She only sees Ahsoka
looking out at the horizon,
so she thinks that Ahsoka is just
like taking it all in when really Ahsoka
is communing with and in force.
Ghost That's the thing with Force Ghost is
they can appear to whoever they want.
So like if you're standing next
to a bunch of people,
the force ghost could just appear to you
if they want, or they could appear
to everyone else to her credit.
Throughout the series, Sabine has gotten
a little bit more powerful
and she can kind of detect Antigone's
force presence nearby.
like I'm feeling
something out there. Something's going on.
I can't quite tell what,
then Ahsoka smiles
because she knows what's going on
and she sees Anakin's force Ghost.
when they do the reveal of Anakin
Skywalker, they also play
some of a soldier's theme music from Star
Wars, The Clone Wars.
So basically they're trying to tell you
that Anakin Skywalker
will probably do something to help them
get back to the main galaxy, like it's
probably called the Pergolas himself
through the force, like,
Hey, we need an assist.
We need a ride back to that galaxy.
I know there are a ton of questions
about what happens next.
Now, the next thing
that's supposed to happen in the timeline
is The Mandalorian Season 4 episodes.
But based on the timing of
when they're going to be filming all this,
it sounds like they either get those out
at the end of next year or like early 20,
25 they've already started
working on Ahsoka Season 2.
I'm assuming that
they'll just continue doing that
now that the strikes have started to end
and they might decide to do that
before the Thrawn movie,
or it might take place
right after the Thrawn movie.
But basically everything in the mando
verse that crosses over now, like Ahsoka
The Mandalorian series,
the Skeleton Crew series,
those are all crossover
and up to the Thrawn movie.
That's kind of like their Star Wars
version of Avengers Endgame.
what they might do, though, is
if things go well with that first movie,
they might just continue
to do the full Thrawn trilogy of movies.
Like the first movie is Heir
to the Empire.
The second movie, Dark Force Rising,
the third movie, The Last Command,
maybe with a different title.
But the basic idea you understand
in between the movie is they'll just do
seasons of these shows
like a Ahsoka Season 2, continuing
seasons of The Mandalorian,
continuing seasons of Skeleton Crew,
or any other spin offs
that they want to develop.
I'm going to need like a whole show
about the Nightsisters.
We just need like a solo show to explain
what's going on with them.
we'll probably get a trailer
for Skeleton Crew pretty soon.
I've already done a trailer
that they dropped back at Star War
Celebration, so I'll link
that in the description below.
some of the big things that they didn't
actually do that I was expecting is
they didn't show us Wes Chatham's face
underneath that stormtrooper armor.
He's playing Enoch
and he's actually a pretty notable actor.
It's weird that they didn't show his face.
maybe they'll do that during the Thrawn
movie or during Ahsoka Season 2 and
Sam Witwer was also credited
in additional voices again,
but I think he did
some of the background voices
when they were raising
all the Nightsister
zombies, yet to picture Dave Filoni giving
him direction from the voiceover booth.
Like, I'm going to need you
to give me some louder evil voices,
evil chanting in the background,
Play with the attitude you have.
I like the attitude of it all. Okay.
All right. In my mind's eye,
Kenobi!
Kenobi!!
I there were so many Easter Eggs
and references
that if you spotted any in the episode
that I didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments
in the next couple of days
I'll do in a serious Season
two video where I talk
more about Baylan Skoll, the Mortis gods,
and all the other big cliffhangers
like Luke Skywalker,
the stuff that they're trying to set up
for the next couple of series
in the Thrawn movie.
click here for that Ahsoka Season 2 video
I'll update the link
as soon as I post that and click here
to learn more about the Mortis gods
and my other Ahsoka episodes.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!